et en août cette parenthèse culture avec
vous axel simon bonjour axel on va
rester dans cette actualité ukrainienne
avec des conséquences évidemment dans le
milieu aussi culturel on commence avec
des annulations en chaîne oui des
répercussions qui touche par exemple la
célèbre biennale d'art contemporain de
venise qui doit être inauguré fin avril
la participation russe a été annulée
suite au retrait ou au boycott du duo
d'artistes qui représentait la russie et
à son commissaire d'exposition en signe
de protestation et on se sent ça chemine
vers la même chose pour le pavillon
ukrainien puisque l'artiste qui a été
choisi pour représenter son pays qui
s'appelle pavlo makhov qui est basée à
kiev a déclaré qu'il n'était plus en
mesure de poursuivre son travail dans de
bonnes conditions et qu'ils étaient en
danger ainsi que ses proches un autre
boycott pour la russie celui du danseur
et chorégraphe français laurent hilaire
il a quitté ce week-end le théâtre
stanislavski de moscou après cinq ans de
la direction de son balai il a sobrement
mais catégoriquement indiqué qu'il ne
pouvait plus poursuivre sa mission dans
le contexte actuel j'ai aussi des
conséquences en dehors de la région oui
dans le monde du cinéma et des séries
par exemple avec l'artiste britannique
brian cox qui incarne notamment le
patriarche dans la série succession qui
a fait hier un discours aux accents
vraiment politique lors de la cérémonie
de remise de récompenses aux sag awards
à los angeles il a rendu hommage au
peuple ukrainien aussi à son président
qui est un ancien acteur on s'en
souvient et puis aux artistes ukrainiens
mais aussi aux artistes russes qui sont
oppressés qui n'ont pas la liberté de
condamner librement la situation et la
guerre on va l'écouter tout de suite
ce qui m'attriste le plus c'est ce qui
se passe en russie le sort réservé à mes
collègues acteur actrice écrivain et
critique on les fait passer pour des
traîtres au premier mot de solidarité
avec l'ukraine je trouve cela horrible
et on devrait tous être derrière eux je
pense aussi aux citoyens russes
et aux artistes nous devons nous joindre
à eux rendre hommage à leur courage en
espérant qu'ils arrivent à changer les
choses et je pense vraiment qu'ils le
peuvent
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà pour brian cox autre
répercussion l'opéra royal à londres qui
a purement et simplement annulé les
représentations prévues avec le bolchoï
le célèbre la célèbre compagnie de
ballet de moscou et puis autre lieu
carnegie hall à new york qui a aussi
annulé ses représentations à venir de
leur caste russe marines qui est à
écarter son chef d'orchestre qui
s'appelle valérie georgiev qui est
réputé proche de vladimir poutine est ce
qu'il y a des répercussions en france
axel aussi wii en un mot jean yves le
drian qui à l'issue du conseil de
défense il ya quelques minutes a pris le
temps dans son bref compte-rendu
d'assurer de la mobilisation du
gouvernement au soutien des artistes
ukrainiens le secteur artistique
français aussi immobilisé à noter une
pétition par exemple de nombreux
directeurs de lieux culturels qui est
relayée par le quotidien libération au
delà d'exprimer leur solidarité l'idée
est de se mobiliser vraiment pour
accueillir les artistes qui sont
contraints de fuir l'ukraine la pétition
a été signée notamment par olivier py lé
directeur du festival d'avignon ou alors
eric ruf qui est le directeur de la
comédie française dernier point quelques
mots la comité de macha méril qui est
originaire d'une famille russe et qui a
vécu en ukraine dès le début de la
guerre la semaine dernière a été l'une
des premières à officiellement prendre
la parole pour condamner la crise la
guerre elle dirige d'ailleurs un
festival de cinéma russe à paris qui
devait s'ouvrir le 21 mars la avant le
week-end elle a indiqué qu'elle comptait
poursuivre ce festival parce qu'en fait
ça donne la parole à des artistes à des
cinéastes russes qui autrement non pas
des espaces pour pouvoir parler merci
beaucoup